okay hi well if you're joining this
livestream I'm here to do a little bit
of software archaeology so this coming
Saturday June 23rd is amazingly enough
the 30th anniversary of the original
release of Mathematica and in
celebration of that we're doing all
kinds of things to celebrate that but
what I was gonna do here was to try to
actually run a mathematical version one
on an actual vintage machine and take a
look at how it worked and compare a
little bit with what we have today so
you know back in June 23rd 1988 the the
one of the more visible things that came
out was this book which I wrote about
Mathematica it was some in those days it
was 750 pages long we could describe
everything in the system now the
corresponding thing is hundreds of
thousands of pages but there's a lot of
very familiar stuff here in fact term I
was just looking let's see well here
that this is this is this is how
Mathematica arrived there were about six
or seven of these disks that were
Mathematica version one came in nice
boxes available at your neighborhood
software store it also came on tapes for
things like Sun workstations and so on
the when we announced Mathematica we had
a big event in Santa Clara California
this was the invitation that see oh my
god this was the invitation there look
at that
it see where we can still compute and
still get the same answer I think that
integral still works out the integrals
don't change you know so I think it's
probably still it's still the same the
anyway the I found I was just looking
through some of the archive material I
kind of I'm an archivist who keeps
everything so I've got all the material
from the original announcement this is
oh yeah this is the
this is kind of examples of what um what
Mathematica did back in the day like
algebraic computation like um oh yeah
you know like it made plots like that so
um and that looks like it was a very
early brochure that we came out when the
system came out there was definitely a
gray and burgundy theme at the company
then oops the facts about Mathematica
just fell out here um oh that's
interesting all kinds of quotes from all
kinds of interesting characters here
quote from Steve Jobs a quote from John
[ __ ] of famous Chaput IBM who is
involved in development of RISC
architectures there is other interesting
quotes here anyway
ok well so I've got let's see what's
this oh this is a good thing
Wow that's really weird so this is an
envelope that says possible names for
Mathematica paren not used well ok well
that's a bit of doodling from back a
long time ago let's see how bad these
are these are really weird these sound
like [ __ ]
they sound like modern weird startup
names well the fancy that I think some
of them are actually machine generated
um well this was a I wonder how many of
these have now been used as actual
startup names by somebody who knows all
right well without further ado let's try
and actually do our piece of software
archaeology and let's try and start
Mathematica up on an old machine so
all right oh there's well that's a Mac
let's try switching it on as a Mac se 30
so it's a slightly modernized version
that was the on/off switch let's see
what happens
oh no this could be a disaster what is
it doing there's a very strange pattern
that it shows looks a bit like a
cellular automaton pattern see what
happens if we will mouse around hmm
come now this cannot fail at the very
beginning let's see when in doubt I
guess it's time to reboot the let's try
switching it off again and see I don't
know about the software the bits don't
rot the hardware different story now why
is it doing this again there's some disk
making funny noises there so this was a
quite modern creature with a hard disk
oh dear well let's see what happens
you think it's listening to its keyboard
or anything hmm
let's see I asked Te'o Gray to virtually
join me maybe he remembers more about
early Mac's than I do yes but that does
not look happy that doesn't look like
any startup pattern I've ever seen
before well this computer was working
earlier so let me see what can we do
what happens if we try putting um when
in doubt how about we take this floppy
disk and what happened what I wonder
what's on this floor it has a hard disk
right but the thing is that pattern
there is coming up long before it could
have read anything off the disk yeah I
know the firmware
satting try sir is there a recent way to
restart the phone um well there is up
I'm just I'm just sort of suspicious
that if I put his district no it's
almost dismayed but but might wake it up
and I think there is a pinhole in the
back somewhere that you can stick a
paperclip in if I'm not mistaken well is
that there's a thing on the front which
clearly has paperclip capable ah right
you could try that but switching on and
off really should have done more or less
the same thing but it can't hurt when in
doubt you know stick a paperclip into an
electrical appliance there I was
thinking what a nice thing to just show
the thing starting from nothing because
after all it just in those days you just
switch computers on and off and well
okay let's just like fit just them maybe
somebody can look up what some what one
does
maybe that pattern maybe we could take a
picture of that pattern and just do an
image search
um the I really have never seen that
pattern before I've seen an awful lot of
you know failures to launch of Mac's but
that is a new one on me someone on the
livestream is suggesting is the
programmers switch attached on the saw
ID oh it doesn't seem too much attached
to the side of this machine you know
what I have a certain tendency to I
think it can do no harm to just pick the
thing up and shake it
anybody got a console just whacking it
also probably what you know just whack
it up just do something
oh come on this is uh slap the CRT
somebody says yeah I agree that's the
that's um I don't know how hard you hit
it I'm out of practice at these things
the that didn't do a damn thing let's
see yeah maybe now our disk is running
maybe turn it off first so the hard disk
isn't getting lucky yeah but what good
is that gonna do what why would this
some well you know if it's has a bad
connection you know pin loose somewhere
and the bad contact with the memory
module or some kind of exit when we
don't have anything
you're not a tool to open this thing do
we know okay all right we'll try one
more time here come on do something so
what back
this is the craziest thing this was
working when and out hmm well let me see
this is no fun at all um I'll tell you
what before okay we're gonna someone
else who is going to try to figure out
what's happened to this Mac and
meanwhile let me um I really want to
want to actually get this to run um wow
that's so crazy it was working fine
alright let me go take a look here
something so what this is there is a
connection a serial port that connects
to a disk there is some kind of parallel
thing here wonder what would happen what
is that there's a funny connector with
this kind of chain like thing as its
icon at the back of the machine I wonder
what that is and I wonder whether
there's a what is this kind of a panel
back there's not a lot that um this
thing is very persistent pattern let me
see
[Music]
um okay so I think I actually have
another SC 30 but it has different set
of problems but we could ah in the
interests of getting something to work
we could try it um I'm just really
disappointed this didn't work well let
me I'll tell you what let's go back over
here and um let me do something else for
a moment here let me go ahead and share
a different thing
stop that sharing and stop showing over
here um you know I have the the the old
um we have a whole scrapbook
it's called Mathematica thirty org of
things so this is this is kind of what
the original um
notebook interface look like very
similar the notebook interface today
hopefully that that's hopefully this is
what we will see very very soon as a
start-up screen that looks just like
that
um and that to me let me let me show you
though if I go back to the original
version one book we can kind of look at
some things like I don't know let's say
the graphics section for example okay
let's see three dimensional plotting
about that um so this is now talking
about plot 3d and I wonder whether we
can just copy paste that hopefully we
can copy/paste that and let's go that's
Meryl
um copy paste something like that into a
nice modern
thing here oh my gosh that pasted us so
that put something completely different
pasted but probably the I wonder whether
this is not allowing me to copy from the
PDF let's try copying that no did not
copy into the clipboard oh dear well
that would be very tiresome I would have
to retype but but we can see some of
these things it's a little ugly looking
here but I think um there's very fine
modern looking syntax let's go look at a
different section this book ah we've got
another ok we are going to try um the
okay we have another se 30 in position
waiting to fail so let's go ahead and
try that there we go okay all right
let's see what happens if I try this SC
30 and switch it on and drumroll come on
this just come
the same pattern that's the craziest
thing that's the craziest thing that is
pretty freaky if I may say so
that I what on earth
women that's now a different pattern why
don't we get the other machine and try
setting that up as well so just just
plug it in and play with it okay what is
it doing what is this one doing so this
one has a mouse that's a good sign
oh look at that what's that saying
that's saying I can't boot great I'm
telling you
hardware is some just the thing to do is
some let's see okay let's see whether we
can um well I'm glad this didn't happen
when we first announced Mathematica and
June 23rd 1988 I think I don't remember
I would kind of guess that we had the
computers all running there that might
have been a good cue for for this event
to do the same thing um what is this
doing let me see I wonder if I just
stick a random disc in there whether it
will show signs of life or whether it
has to have a system disc I could always
put an unopened Mathematica version one
sample notebooks discus in it and see
what happens and see what happens I can
take that disc and stick it in there I
don't think this is very likely to
produce good results but might be kind
of interesting to see
and just claw it said no thank you
that's not a system boot disk Oh
somebody's saying there's a problem of
the rom connection memory is making a
bad contact you think that that's what
causes that particular yeah I say if you
could take it apart the thing to do
would be to wiggle the memory modules
you know well let's just plug in that
computer um you might want to do that
okay hold on
well we may have to reschedule this this
is this is deeply unpromising I'm afraid
my apologies for somebody is sending us
repairing a vintage Mac se 30 yeah okay
that's a good oh try command option PR
to clear the parameter Ram that is an
interesting idea um okay you think
that's gonna work on that other machine
all right let me let me go ahead and
hold on let's let's let's let's just
take this machine I think this machine
that the one we just set up is not going
to work I think that's hopeless okay and
let's keep that out of the UM okay so
let's try machine number one and we got
a whole parade of Maca see 30s here two
of them actually
and that one I would say we switch it
off and let's just go ahead here and
take the power out of that one move it
away and plug this one move that one up
so the camera can see it and then plug
the same now these identical or not they
both look identical
the mouse and the keyboard look
identical it's probably some clever
piece of early design plug them in okay
and now let's go back over here and now
I'm gonna try this okay okay
command option PR command option P I
think you have to hold that down while
it boots right come on don't turn it off
and hold those keys down then switch it
on and wait until you hear a tone okay
switch it off I'm holding down those
keys this is the craziest thing so I
mean what this is this what it's
separating the video memory basically
did it ever make a tone like a tone yeah
so this is like deeply not working
okay but I think we'd take it apart and
find any chips that are plugged into
sockets and wiggle them great but it
requires that special tool to take it
apart to do special tools well you need
a torx which is not so weird anymore but
then you need to sort of hinge spreader
thing although you can just sort of
finagle it to get it apart all right I
think we're gonna give up here um so uh
well okay maybe we can at least look at
something gosh what I was hoping to do
was to take a bunch of old Mathematica
version 1.0 code and move it over and
run it in version 11 and the most things
just work great which is always a
pleasure and it's nothing like this
experience where the I'm actually kind
of interest in this pattern I wonder
what this pattern is I can't term it
mates makes me kind of want to just take
a picture of that pattern and try and
analyze it um but I I don't think that's
very useful it is a I mean what kind of
smells like bits you know it looks like
bytes you can probably figure out what
the numbers are yeah and what good is
that gonna do us not gonna show us that
a piece of video memory has crud written
on it that is I mean this is just a
mapping of video memories that what will
you see on the screen okay presumably I
mean assuming that the video output
chips are working properly as opposed to
what what do you think this otherwise
isn't mean it's clearly something
digital but it's not yeah right I mean
no it's gotta be it's just that's what's
in the video memory right for what I
believe is main memory in that model I
think that you know there's there's not
like there's separate video memory
I don't think okay
so it could actually just be you know
the video output pointing at some random
place in memory before it's even set up
the notion of where is the video memory
all right look I think what we're gonna
do is this I'm when in gosh we got to
Mackay c37 neither of them work we have
other Oh what just happened it just
changed the screen just changed did you
see that
oh my gosh that's the crane
this thing it's booting what on earth
has happened wowie oh my gosh well okay
do I dare to move it an inch forward
perhaps not that's the craziest thing
well okay
persistence pays off I guess not that I
did in a thing Wow
okay well that that um all right let's
Wow okay
I'm gonna wait for TARDIS to stop
running and then I'm going to do it
terribly scary thing and try and move it
until you bit forward because I think it
will work better don't fail there we go
okay hey this is cool alright well look
at that we could start up there we go
let's see if I still know how to work
something like this yeah I'm sorry about
the flashing it's some it's the the
webcam that we have doesn't interact
perfectly with the with a refresh rate
of the screen and who knows maybe this
thing has okay so there we go
so let's see I don't know what math a
and B and things are but let's try
double cooking on Mathematica wake up
wake up there we go
look at that Mathematica I don't oh yeah
okay so there we go there's a window so
let's try the the tried-and-true 2+2 and
there's a cell shift enter let's see
what happens now that thing on the
bottom there that thing there that's the
memory monitor so that's showing it just
use the megabyte of memory it's heading
for 1.25 megabytes of memory is it gonna
make it how much memory is gonna take to
do 2+2
da da okay it managed to get four
congratulations to it let's see whether
it managed my test always let's try
something more modest
100 factorial okay that worked now my
test for computers in their speed is
always 1989 to the power 1989 which I
think I only started doing in 1989
because it didn't work so well in 1988
so let's see how it does on this
computer ok you know this is absolutely
instantaneous like millisecond time
timescale in today's world this may be a
terrible mistake oh my gosh what's
happening here the hmm maybe this is why
I only started doing this in 1989 it cuz
it just ran too slowly here it's gonna
it's gonna come back I know it's gonna
come back well at least I think it's
gonna come back it's not using any more
memory at least well what's that thing
tell you what's that thing the little
gray piece in the top I believe that is
system allocated but free within the
Mathematica allocator ah look at that
look at that look at that we succeeded
now unfortunately this you know in
today's world if I move that cursor back
it would just um it would just
continuously scroll but in in those days
when did we add continuous scrolling
sometimes yeah it was pre version 3 okay
it required you know couple orders of
magnitude an improvement in speed before
that made sense okay so let's try doing
something else let's try okay so that
succeeded although it took a ridiculous
Crowell wheel here and there isn't there
isn't there's no scroll wheel alright
let's try something else let's try that
integral that was in the in the brochure
um oh no that's most terrible
see what happens if I just say you think
a modern version of that internal tables
calm would work oh look at that it's
using more memory that's a little scary
I didn't know it I didn't know it
required that initialization there must
have been a special thing on the Mac
that wasn't true on the workstation
version the workstation versions it just
worked but here look at that bit scary
here because the memory usage is
creeping up creeping up okay okay let's
see all right let's try go back there
and let's see whether it manages to make
it Oh amazing
now it's perhaps entered got interesting
to see let's see whether if you look
sort of inside the belly of the creature
does it have things like that yeah it
does look at that just like today um now
let's try let's try something like let's
try to plot I would be able to try and
play asking a lot really I remember I
remember it is about a minute and a half
for plot sine of X and but that may have
been slightly before just that looked
like a Mac plus no there we go look at
that came out just fine now and look at
that it's even got resize handles all
those not that and then neither nice and
orange but that was the wait cursor yeah
I only just saw the wait cut it for a
moment that that weird string figure
thing how do I get to see the really
admire the wait cursor um okay so let's
try let's try 3d plots let's do the
characteristic sine X Y X 0 3 y 0 3 is
this going to look a little it's a
little bit I mean I'm running right well
I'm not at the edge of memory yet oh
look at that look at that look at that
and there's no bite cursor what's that
you missed the wait cursor oh did I miss
the way precursor now this is do I get
to do anything with this can I pick this
up and rotate it around or is that are
my ten years too early for that
this is PostScript this is pre hidden
surface removal yeah so this is not
real-time so this is something so if I
said show this viewpoint oh and it
doesn't have them
Oh terrible turtle it doesn't have
auto-completion um let's just try some
random few points is that gonna work or
is that gonna fail horribly should work
I Oh beautiful now we have in 3d
graphics - we had 3d graphics but do we
have spheres and 3d graphics I think you
had a load of package ah oh well that's
no good okay well let's try I see okay
now the other thing we could do here
where was that so that required some
kind of sample oh that's packages well
why oh so it doesn't have the packages
discs well I've got a packages disc here
I can surely load it in let's take a
look I've got a whole array of discs
here what does this say disc just two
three four five sample notebooks for
where are the packages hmm well that's
no good maybe it's in utilities why
would it be in utilities it says
packages samples one two three but I
only have samples one and two and I have
a thing called utilities but let's see
if the utilities there's anything use
useful one might think something called
utilities would have useful stuff what's
the label after 30 years has come off
this floppy disk let's pull the label
out before it gets stuck in the innards
of the Mac okay let's see what happens
here please locate this file or click
cancel if you don't want to open it okay
let's go to utilities here oh no that's
something totally irrelevant okay okay
well that didn't look all right let's
try some things like some of our our
friends like nest list I think nest
ghost was alive and well in those days
oh it looks great now I think um let's
see I get the old
Mathematica book and let's see what some
what kinds of things we can do there um
yeah there's all kinds of things let's
see I've got tongue should we do some
math should we do some oh yeah there's
all kinds of um we could do actually the
one thing let's see if we can get let's
take a look at some of the menus here um
oh gosh I have to hold down a lot of
settings what would I have there display
graphics color color doesn't do us much
good on a black and white machine what
does it say here oh my gosh that's how
to do do the patterns for density plots
and things like that's but let's go to
the action menu this under kernels we
should be able to get a remote kernel
except I don't think this machine is
connected to a network that's sad
because otherwise we could potentially
connect this very very old Mac to a very
modern kernel that would be a cool
little hack but it wasn't Matt link at
that time was it yes it was it was
absolutely well the the yeah the remote
kernel connection absolutely was math
link the local kernel connection wasn't
but the remote one was what would happen
if I just selectively remote kernel what
it'll probably come up with some
dialogue well maybe it doesn't do
anything
why would where would the where would
how would I set well that's probably
gonna be a fail how would I set the oh
it's still set to local kernel it
refused to set itself to remote kernel
um how would I set up the remote kernel
as a style menu well you have to be on a
network for one thing well yes I realize
that well maybe it knows it isn't on a
network maybe it was cover enough to
know that um alright let's see what else
can I do do we let's have some requests
anybody want to try anything out here um
we could I'm looking through the version
one book oh yeah it's always always good
oh gosh I keep on trying to run a scroll
wheel
you know I encountered a copy of that
book in the wild just yesterday
really yes my guess where no I well yes
yes all right no I can't I can't guess
well a science-based escape room
well it wasn't part of the clue there
wasn't like a clue in it it's just a
prop okay the thing I'd really like to
do here there's there's a bunch of code
in the book and what will be cool is to
take that code and run it in wow I
didn't remember we had that okay look
this is an interesting thing to try so
if I say and a PI comma 200 or something
okay that works fine there is a weird
function here called recognize which is
a precursor of modern things let's see
what that does
okay refuses to work because it isn't an
algebraic number but I think if I do if
I copy what's in the book here um and
then let's see I couldn't copy/paste
straight from this cell there's no
harmony there's no problem in doing that
oh I don't know what they did there but
okay so I copied that pasted that there
and I can run it oh it still doesn't
work hmm well whatever um I don't know
why I'd probably have to oh that's
because this is that's because I'm
looking at the section of the book
that's about a package that's that
actually confused me for a minute
because I thought um okay let's see what
else could we try doing we could try
doing solving equations we could try
doing mathematical functions we could
try someone there's a scheme for a link
to the book yeah you can um help browser
there what's that the help browser how
could the help browser be there didn't
have room it barely had room to store
the code let alone the the documentation
well but there was the various
down there so what happens if I just
type of question mark
okay let's try typing question mark star
if we really want to live dangerously
oh no this may okay there we go yeah
yeah good okay so let's actually try I'm
sure we can say names of star and then
we can say slash slash length and that's
really anemic 682 that's so sad if I do
that today I'll get like come 6,000 it's
10x some improvements so to speak but
let's take a look at some of the things
that are in here I mean there's some
we've got all kinds of funky elliptic
functions all kinds of package control
functions um we've got loops well let's
try how about we do this let's try
taking do we have from let's try doing I
think I'm trying to remember how we
would get a random well that's not very
helpful why doesn't this tell us I think
I might have to look in the book here um
let's see random yes I thought that's
how it worked why doesn't it give us
documentation maybe it just doesn't have
any documentation loaded um and uh yeah
we changed this actually and um um right
we changed how that works it's now
random integer it's one of the few
changes like that that um got made let's
see let's try doing I'm I was thinking I
could try writing a little piece of code
here let's say table um let's say table
oh we I assume we have disks disk random
let's try table random real 10 comma 2
let's make ten of those that gonna work
amazing and now let's say graphics of
that that was rather unhelpful of it oh
maybe I have to say show ah okay not so
bad
that's right because graphics was not um
okay so what I need to do that I think
this wasn't defaulting yet - I think I
have to say table random real there
comma let's say one and it takes a
little while to run there let's say
graphics of that slash slash show and
Donna okay now I wonder whether that
works was there a sphere yet no there
was no sphere so in 2d there were
polygons but they weren't yet spheres um
yeah I think the spheres came came
significantly later but here let's let's
see we can probably try doing let's just
try doing 50 discs and we didn't have
opacity but we certainly had and we
wouldn't have had color so that won't
work but we could presumably have gray
level so we could presumably say in here
gray level random comma disk why is this
not line wrapping the code tayo why
didn't this line up the co-op's
because you don't want a wine rep code
nobody line wraps code weddings ma no
space tax if you don't like wrap it um
that's newfangled typesetting systems
yeah that's right well I came in a few
years later all right let's try this
so we claimed to have different gray
levels let's see whether that works and
let's try showing this oh there's the
weight coaster coming up look at that
wait cursor see that snazzy white cursor
and look at those bizarre grade this
now you know it's a little bit weird
that they are with an aspect ratio um
let's see if I say show that aspect
ratio to automatic boy command
completion really helps um aggghhhhh
see if that works now that are
magnificent it's a little bit
disquieting to see those kind of fabric
patches get drawn was that the best was
that our did the patents or was that
some max time I believe those are quick
ride to their patterns I don't think we
made those up I don't think so
well but I saw in that menu in the
configuration menu someplace here
where was the configuration menu there
was a setup menu where was it or was it
windows that's it was a I just saw it
there was a menu where would it be could
it be under window might be oh look
let's let's look at about Mathematica oh
yes oh yes oh and there's all the secret
buttons in there Wow well and also look
at this there was there was the cellular
Taunton yes well but then their secret
buttons that will make that go film a
whole area oh yeah how do you do that I
think try clicking a little bit to the
right of the rightmost checkbox
yeah it's click around a little you know
all rounded there it is you're
absolutely right just filled the whole
area I mean what it's doing here it's
very unclear but but Tim okay so if I
try and make I'm clear it's in
transparently I'll be a cellular
automata yes it is transparently obvious
and if I if I could do my big spare
button on the left will randomize okay
well isn't that cool Wow you never know
what you're gonna find in here now I
took many more years before oh there's
rule 110 well there I think there's
actually a another secret button if you
could grab them I can go full screen
look around where you were with this the
hidden buttons over there well we have
come later look at that there you go
that's the craziest thing you know we
didn't add actual cellular automaton
functionality to the language until
version until sometime right around the
time the MKS book came out in 2002
probably because I couldn't figure out
cellular automata is sort of very
generally parametrized will program Zand
I couldn't figure out a good way to
specify sort of all the ones one would
want you know in a clean fashion but
okay well anyway there's there's some I
get out of this well I was gonna say I
have no idea I mean Escape key maybe
would be the first thing to try okay
okay let's try that
oh you were absolutely right the escape
queue is right um the let's see the
question is there's probably now more
people who know about that hidden button
than it did at the time
well yes um let's see how about
reproducing the logo yeah that's a good
idea
um the okay let's try it let's see
whether we can okay as our perhaps final
act in them in trying to unless we have
more requests for things to try let's
some in a little bit of memory we have
left here let's try reproducing the logo
so I think we need to load oh no but we
need to load the polyhedra and where on
earth all the polyhedra maybe the
polyhedra are missing I wonder whether
there's other disks here well let's see
the poly polygon let's try doing this
let's try making a table of random reels
size 10 table their food and let's just
make let's try doing this this will live
a bit dangerous Lee let's try doing
table of let's set
and this may be this may be really
horrendous 30 polygons and let's do a
show graphically you know I really hate
this this thing that that I have to
actually type new lines in the code and
I also hate the fact that it doesn't
have syntax colouring now how do i how
am I supposed to figure out whether
those brackets close quickly I need one
more 30 does not Oh piffle that's that's
that's modern times okay
what do you mean it's not a list of
three numbers polygons Oh Oh polygons
requires if I want to make triangles I
have to make a list of 3 comma 3 right
yeah that's going to make a list of 3
triples for the coordinates in 3d space
and we're waiting we're waiting now why
isn't that wait cursor I thought that
what when does the wait cursor come up
is it the equivalent of planting of the
yes when the I mean that when the kernel
was running the front end is not blocked
so you can still do stuff so there's no
wait cursor it's why the front end is
blocking actually let's try can I do
come on 4 and start typing in um no how
do I get a section heading go to style
your style yeah cell style oh wait a
minute it said come on 4 was a section
heading just like today but probably
only worked when you actually had
something selected maybe not an
insertion point ah maybe okay let's try
it let's try but then what would I have
to do here how would I start typing and
I couldn't have had to start typing and
then well question that seems very silly
you could always tell that option key
command option 4 by the way you're about
out of memory see if it starts so if
we're lucky we'll start increasing the
size of the gray area now as it purges
stuff rather than you think I can do you
know what I could just kill the input
and output lines that would that would
save some memory
yeah but not while it's reading well
maybe I have to kill it and then do that
but I'm a little bit confused by this
whole thing about if I do come on seven
okay that worked that was nice
that's like a nice modern notebook setup
wait a bit what about a cell group hey I
wanted to see a cell group but this
didn't auto group here I don't meet
those cells and their cell group cells
okay so then we had Auto grouping look
at that isn't that amazing
oh yeah look at these yeah these are
really cool yeah we have to look at
those those are fun let's let some okay
let's try and have this thing not die um
do I do come on period I think so local
kernel interrupts Wow so try Bart I
could try bought or I could try actually
quit the kernel let's try bought mmm not
hopeful let's try it let's try let's try
something more violent let's try
quitting the kernel because then we can
still do you really want to quit the
kernel sure boom now until you begin a
new session why is it telling me that
what what do you mean until I well okay
look a look at look at that look at how
much memory we just saved now okay while
we're doing that I want to show
something with the cell group in
business so let's see if I put a title
cell up here how can i how can I not
have to type so you say if I do option
like you should be able to type command
1 and then start typing I think that
ever didn't work that just seems so
anyway at this point you could do
command option 1 and that should convert
the whole cell well I'm having it now
now what I wanted to do is I want to go
ahead and select everything which I
assume is still kimande no it wasn't
come on day well how would I select
everything can I drag select yeah no I
can't drag so it because it can't can I
shift select yeah why can't you drag
cycle should be able to
because I can't drag now because it
doesn't drag on a scroll
it doesn't notice cull weird didn't seem
to be auto-scrolling okay so now if I
select everything what I want to do is I
want to say group all those cells um and
now in a piece of drama look at that
yes look at that amazing horizontal
thing which almost is like one of those
mini views so here make a new input cell
below without opening that okay and then
option click on its cell bracket option
click yeah well it's giving me some
weird hand here that doesn't look good
it just cuz when I hold down the option
key it it gives me a hand
command click try that I'm sorry click
on the cell bracket yeah no but look at
this this is that this is a nice modern
thing and we had started the regalia of
cell brackets here what did that what
did that little check mark thing naming
snot evaluatable okay same is what I
wanted to show is the thing where you
can do a find and you can see right yeah
an option click on a cell bracket area
selected all the input cells but oh so
what do I do here I find ya there and so
what do I do here I just put in
something like X maybe and then click on
and then all oh yeah look at that it's
kind of like a like some kind of um you
know gel will something for you know
yeah I mean that was actually slightly
useful functionality that we lost at
some point for well I mean so what
that's showing is where which cells in
the cell bracket it's kind of a mini of
you I'm sure somebody's claimed that
they invented many views but the let's
see
what yeah I mean so that was that was
showing where that there was nothing you
could you couldn't click oh wait oh that
cleared this clear the select I know you
selected the whole thing now yeah okay
alright what else can we show here what
other what are the cool things are there
there were a lot of stuff to do with
conversion to PostScript wasn't that
exciting no cell contents should think
oh that might work yeah let's see
whether that works so let's say I go
down here and why did I have graphic
there we go there's a nice graphic what
would I do I could say what would I do
here I would say oh look all those
things with page breaks and so on um oh
there's the settings down there let's
look at action oh wow
new output replaces old output cells are
grouped with input ok multiple output
cells grouped together
beep run an evaluations finished how do
we get it to beep that was another
interesting feature and what happens if
i press help oh how we get a wait cursor
oh well that's interesting
we did a test at the time of version
three we did test a focus group with
longtime users where we had them open
the physical box and comment on
different components in it one of the
big components in the box was this big
thick manual about how to use the user
interface and most of the people in that
focus group looked at that thing and I
remember them kind of holding it up and
saying wow I never knew this was in here
in other words none of them had ever
even opened it which was the last time
we tried to document to user interface
in in textual form like that well at
least until our modern workflows um but
what I was looking for was the the
remote kernel configuration stuff that
must have been here somewhere um I'm
thinking well what else would be under
settings maybe startup wow this is icy
weather to load integration rules that
start up whether to use whether it'll
automatically start a local kernel ok
the stack size requested 256 kilobytes
of stack size you know the really
terrible thing about modern computers is
you still have to do things like
allocate so well maybe you don't anymore
maybe maybe the stack size is finally
just grows um down from the top of
memory and the heap grows up from the
bottom of memory maybe that's no longer
maybe that finally got fixed you don't
have to do have to I think with like
Java you still have to declare all that
stuff um what what is in the kernel menu
under action well Colonel menu which
yeah under the action menu the colonel
said menu it seemed to just have these
things for remote kernel and when I did
the remote cone with just refused to do
anything mm-hmm just it just was dead so
maybe it knows that this computer isn't
connected to anything that would allow
it to yeah it's um but you you would get
like a place you could put in an IP
address or something well I think you
could buy a place where you put on a
phone number yes yes you could actually
maybe we have to maybe I wonder if we
have we I don't think we have a modem or
anything that would pretend to be a
modem here
um let's see uh well what's mathematica
help oh well with something here that's
a notebook oh look at that
there's help on menus and we could like
search for the we could search for
things here dialog box help well no
there we go there's that there's the the
dialog box um oh yeah what I wanted to
show is all the stuff with the with the
why the beep because that was one of the
very obscure things was it would just
beat and you couldn't tell wider deep
tanned so we added a why the beep under
here why the beep oh we also have
explains selection limit you tried to oh
it oh it did beep but this poor
Macintosh's is mute I think this
Macintosh tried to beat out in the
network window that's the secret there
is there in the Windows menu you must
first open the network window and log
into a remote computer before select
here oh okay oh yes so it is we should
read the old documentation ok so there's
a network window now what happens I
think that's a terminal emulator ok here
we go
okay so hang up phone log out ok
terminal there we go 300 board we can we
can work at 300 board here umm and I
knew that must be some use CRC error
correction that's cool now let's see
edit Corrections what is direct mean um
edit connections those are those are
autodialers yeah those are those are a
TDT I remember that now if only we had
before only we could connect this to a
cell phone and actually dial something
we'd be in great shape
um hmm I don't know how you get bad from
here it would be interesting to see I
think this would work I think that that
if we were to connect it to a modern
kernel I think there was a good chance
that we'll be able to talk to it um
do you want no no well anyway what else
can we show here it's cool all this
stuff works I I'm I'm mum I'm still
completely mystified what happened to
this computer oh yeah there are all
kinds of things here for changing
themselves let's take a look at on the
livestream if people have any questions
here um let me say bring back the
mini-map was full form control e around
in version one let's [ __ ] that out I
don't actually know let's see so you
know I don't wanted to save changes so
what I was trying to do was to do let's
try control II didn't do anything I can
command shift e you know but I know
that's the modern version I thought oh
yeah yeah yeah well come on shift e just
appeared to redraw it hmm well um let's
see any other look on yourself there
should be a menu item there for it I
thought there would be up but I didn't
see it
um Oh formatted and then we could go to
unformatted great oh there we go oh
that's really wild look at what that is
okay who knows what that is
Bette listen people on this live stream
would know what that is that is
PostScript code that's the PostScript
code that draws the that draws that
graphic um
which you can edit and get a different
graphics that's wild try it on the show
command because it's obviously not gonna
be boxes but what is it I don't think
it's anything I think the format of non
formatted version is are the same let's
see for answered what what do you mean
can't format itself
see I see the the notion of formatted is
something that toggled between I think
the the unformatted graphics and this so
let's see um somebody's asking saying
it's impressive that the front-end
design looks almost the same now have we
considered completely rethinking it from
scratch yeah yeah and and have comes the
conclusion in many cases that it doesn't
actually make any sense and that
actually there's a reason why for
example books haven't really been
redesigned for what is it five hundred
years now it's the things that actually
just work um let's see modern okay so
nobody wants to see statistics I don't
know how much statistics stuff we
actually had in version let's take a
look let's take a look I think we had
some let's just try doing a table yeah
and by the way the people who are
completely rethinking user interfaces
for computational interactive documents
seem to consider copying notebooks to be
the most effective way of yes yes that's
right it seems like a a indeed that that
seems to be the the the latest and
greatest thing um as we can see it's
half you know thirty years is about half
the total time that digital computers
have been seriously used so okay now how
what happened here we know kernel local
kernel I want a local kernel okay so
let's try this with my local kernel you
may have to start it manually how do I
start a kernel mmm good question I would
have thought it was in the action menu
what do you think so oh look at that
doesn't make template that that's right
there was a complete selection even from
the very beginning oh and look at this
what what are the color selector do on a
black and white
why do we even have a color sir what
were their color looks like what is that
and what a 3d viewpoint select it was
cool that you should try that oh yeah
this was cool yeah this was the only
real-time thing that you can actually
move yeah I had to make it hide I had to
make it grow out the lines in the back
by hand huh well why do what why is this
not working why is the and maybe I have
to restart the whole thing let's try
that well what about I'm gonna try and
save this oh yeah yeah it's not a
separate process you can't just go
around starting a new curve really yeah
I think it's not the process okay where
am I gonna save this I don't really have
a good scheme let's see what do we call
this I would I would say save this
document as retro - oh one now what
happens if I try and save oh look at
that that's that same that's crazy that
it still has that same saving percentage
whatever thing um you're right it is
amusing that people think that notebook
so the are the the latest modern thing
it's rather charming it's also charming
that we had a physical address that's
how it feels like you know kind of a I'm
one of those gdpr like things you know
have your physical address on your piece
of software um let's see what were we
trying to do we were trying to make a
table primes and now we have to start up
again hmm and I know I think things like
list plot were absolutely alive and well
back in those days
there are Pines let's some duelists
plotz Dada
I'm in that plot a lot of times in my
life okay what are we going to do we
were going to try somebody wanted to see
some statistics yeah so let's try
percent one that was the list of primes
and let's see I don't know whether we
had to see what a mean as it was in
there for example yeah I think that was
still only as a package and I think um
well let's just do this let's go ahead
whoops it didn't work - just do delete
upon a group of cells so command X
worked okay so let's do apply plus 2%
one divided by length percent one and
that should give us the rather inelegant
and we didn't have typesetting at that
time so those were sort of them that was
an inelegant term form of typesetting I
mean I think it's sort of interesting to
see let's try doing some factoring here
let's see maybe I will definitely kill
it but see if we can do something like
that oh yeah that worked fine um I
noticed that it did do all the line
breaking correctly and I think things
like short we're alive and well I think
I wrote that original code yeah of short
work just fine back then um I think when
it comes to let's look at some like
functional programming things I wonder
whether we had I think that we had a
thing called accumulate yes that did
what fold does now and this was
gradually deprecated and actually
accumulate was reused many many many
years later although does the same
things um yeah so so um let's see what
else can we do with them let me look up
I I just love doing all this functional
programming stuff because that was all
your patterns are of course an important
thing which some work just fine I wonder
what happens if we say oh yeah and their
functions like go to which I've never
used in my
all time of using our language um let's
see they're things like where do we have
let's try doing some of the I'm looking
through for the fancy functional
programming stuff and I'm not where is
that section it probably didn't we
probably didn't call it functional
programming in those days because that
would sound too too scary um there's a
big big section on um oh yeah yeah
there's some funky things which I guess
we still have this was an example of
thumb that is a weird function which has
never turned out to be all that useful
um in all these years but I think if we
say you know there are things like this
and I think we can and all of the kinds
of things like if we say outer let's try
something like this outer times let's
try making a multiplication table oh
yeah let's try making them okay so this
should make a twelve by twelve
multiplication table and if we say table
let's try doing matrix form I think that
existed that there we go very nice
there's a multiplication table um now in
those days we couldn't do the kind of
typesetting type stuff for putting
separators in there and so on oh yeah
somebody wants to see dollar version
very good question let's see what this
actually is
oh this is that's a cheat this is a
later version that's probably because
the disks we didn't have disks from the
actual one point oh that's shocking
that's some let's see the
all right well one-one let's see any
last things we can try doing here
someone is suggesting what would it look
like if you could with tiling cells like
one can insert cells similar to tabs I
don't know I don't know I think come you
know the idea of spreadsheets obviously
is a is a ridge array of cells that's
you know a different model
I think we found I mean I you know most
of the deviations that we've had from
this kind of presentation have not been
very successful um but anyway well I
think well I'm glad this some computer
finally started to behave somebody asked
for the how to get to that legacy
documentation and maybe we can just find
that and wrap up with a few things on a
modern modern version what's some let's
go there so here let's go and share a
different screen here um okay so this
was first of all reference TOCOM slash
legacy slash me one seems to be the the
legacy documentation um I think we we
really wanted to make with that we had
fonts at the top we really wanted to
make people who just landed on this page
know that this was not intended to be a
modern thing they shouldn't go here and
say you know it's some back when I was
like I it's it's terrible what people
find on the web and then think is
definitive back when I was about 12
years old I I wrote this kind of book
like thing about physics and eventually
I put that on the web actually when I
was 13 I wrote one about particle
physics and that's on the web somewhere
and I it has some kind of legend that
basically says I wrote this when I was
13 because otherwise I was was worried
people are going to quote a bunch of
stuff about quantum field theory from
that some from that book which which
would probably be a mistake anyway let's
just try and let's try it here's a nice
modern
point three let's try let's try my 1989
to the 1989 and see what happens now
bump there we go so remember before on
the other machine it was taking forever
to do that now it's sort of
instantaneously and we can probably even
if we just say repeated timing of that
okay very small fraction of a second and
remember we had 682 functions I think
let's let's see how many functions we
have here length of names of star would
give us the functions in here and okay
so almost 10x the number of functions
and maybe we could just do you know the
same things I was doing just just over
there I could do I bet that it still
works to do just pure random but I don't
think it likes it yeah it still works
still compatible because we want to be
able to run code that comes from 30
years ago but it's not some oh that's
nice it's a lot more syntax coloring
here but so that would work so we could
probably do the exact same thing we did
there we could do table of gray level of
random open clothes of disk of random
real table that and we can do this just
exactly the same as I was typing over
there comma 1 this thing and then I
could do this and I could say how many I
did there I think I only did 20 there
but but and then I can just say graphics
of that no notice I don't have to do the
show anymore if I do the show it's not
going to hurt anything
but there's the as the result probably
here we could just perfectly well we can
do as many as we want and it will be
happy as could be and we don't even see
um probably if we if we ask to I wonder
what would happen if we asked to
rasterize this we could probably I we
never see do the patterns here I guess
not not the way it works anymore
um anyway and nowadays if we want to get
a spiky which we were having trouble
with there because it was on a disk we
didn't have you just say spiky and you
can say I'm well let's say we take that
and we just make ask for an image of
that and we should get a nice no there
we go
there's a nice spiky because we've
upgraded the spiky back in the day that
was a oh no that's just the image I
should I needed a 3d graphic of it um
anyway the back in the day that was some
a plain stellated icosahedron but now
we've upgraded to this rhombic hexagon
he drew um okay and and yeah indeed we
can we do have the documentation as
somebody is saying from 1988 so if you
still have a somebody has the complete
version one discs out there version 1.0
you know I seem to have some discs from
version 1.0 that I just found in my
archive box this evening but I don't
seem to have I seem to have utilities
and sample notebooks yeah so I think
time to time to look a little bit more
Catholic for those or maybe I should
just go try and buy them on eBay um well
okay thanks um thanks all for joining us
sorry that that term got off to a bit of
a slow start here absolute mystery what
happened to that Mac and I'm Thao do you
have any ideas what could what on earth
could take 15 minutes for a piece of
electronics to I have no clue I mean
nothing like that ever happened to me
back in the day
bizarre oh well anyway well thanks for
joining us everybody and it's so we'll
be doing a few more things in
celebration of our 30th anniversary a
lot it's
it's cool to see that the stuff we built
that long ago still makes sense and that
if I could if I had a way to just move
code from this old Mac over to my new
machine I would find that it still ran
which I find very satisfying and it's
something we intend to maintain in the
future so that people who write code
today can expect in another 30 years one
hopes even if not all of us are still
running then for the for the code to
still run all right thank you very much
and good night